die afd aktuell stärkste kraft im osten
und das ist inzwischen völlig egal mit
wie viel rechtsextremen sie öffentlich
marschieren oder weil sie nicht welchen
vogelschutz bullshit der gauland
herausrückt egal die umfragen bleiben
top wir fragen uns was ist also das
erfolgsgeheimnis der afg sprechen wir
darüber mit der renommierten heute-show
parteien forscherin birte schneider ja
bitte wie machen die das
also erstmal herr welke die müssten gar
nichts machen
die kamikaze groko zerlegt sich ja
weiter selbst aus einem todestrieb
heraus dessen ursachen uns noch nicht
ganz klar sind also die afg könnte sich
also einfach zurücklehnen und kommen
lassen aber die denken ja schon weiter
der kampf um die gehirne unserer kinder
hat begonnen
hier auf dieser seite der afg hamburg
sollen schüler ab sofort lehrer melden
die sich kritisch mit der afd
auseinandersetzen oder lehrer die die
afg einfach tot schweigen und gar nicht
behandeln also im unterricht nicht über
die afg reden ist verboten schlecht über
die afg reden ist verboten
aber da bleiben ja noch viele andere
möglichkeiten
ja also eine denunziation hotline
schüler verpetzen lehrer
das ist deutschland menschen die sich
gegenseitig bei der partei verpfeifen es
hat bei uns immer funktioniert und die
schulen sind ja nur der anfang es kommen
schon die ersten anzeigen aus der kita
hier die vierjährige lena aus der
igelgruppe hat der afd dieses bild
gemalt es zeigt wie sie links grün
versifften spinat essen musste während
die erzieherin eine schwule fahne
schwenkt das wird nicht ohne folgen
bleiben
ich habe gelesen die afg macht das
demnächst auch an schulen in berlin das
ist doch pure einschüchterung nicht nur
es geht auch darum jetzt schon mal
listen anzulegen damit man nach der
macht ergreift nach nach dem wahlsieg
weiß wo die linken lehrer arbeiten
beziehungsweise dann nicht mehr arbeiten
außerdem ist das notwehr
wissen sie eigentlich wie es an unseren
schulen mittlerweile aussieht und wenn
schüler eine der glücklichen schulen mit
bereits implementierte erziehung zur
sogenannten sexualität der vielfalt
besuchen dürfen dann meine damen und
herren dann ist sichergestellt dass sie
am ende der vierten klasse besser
kondome über gummi penisse rollen können
als das große in kleine einmaleins
das ist fakt selbst im mathe
leistungskurs wird nur noch mit gummi
penissen gerecht
meldet lehrer die mit gummi penis zur
schule kommen was was es mit dem
richtigen penis grauzone
herr welke die afg sagt es geht hier um
das neutralitätsgebot für lehrer dass es
ja wirklich gibt was die afg aber
verschweigt lehrer sind auch
verpflichtet für die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung einzutreten
parteiprogramme zu analysieren und
darauf hinzuweisen wenn grundwerte
missachtet werden gehört eigentlich auch
zum job da hatte ich auch kann man sich
denn gar nicht wehren gegen dieses
ewigen spitzel warum denn demnächst
sitzen da in hamburg und berlin afd
mitarbeiter und müssen die ganzen mails
von teenagern bearbeiten höchststrafe
liebe schüler vor dem fernseher die ihr
gerade mit euren eltern die heute show
guckt erstens ihr könnt eure eltern
schon dafür melden dass sie mit euch
diese linke scheiß sendung
gruppen-zweiter schick der afg hamburg
doch einfach alle möglichen beschwerden
einfach was euch nervt keine ahnung wenn
eure freundin scheinen sich ein total
doof ist justin bieber tattoos stechen
lassen wenn ihr mal so eine matte nicht
kapiert wenn ihr das neue album von
drake vor allem findet glaubt mir die
afg interessiert sich für alles
bitte schreibt denn so oft ihr könnt
[Applaus]
[Musik]